Lake tag on the foothills of the
Bavarian Alps
for centuries the Benedictine abbey that
was founded in the mid 80 to find life
here in the region later on the royal
house of wittelsbach played a dominant
role at the st. fili newest parish
church the family often welcomed Royals
from all over Europe
in the early 19th century king
maximilian of bavaria turned the abbey
into his summer residence
this hog bought the all people the
closure of the abbey in 1803 was a major
milestone in the history of the valley
it was only when the royal family turned
the former abbey into their summer
residence that the region had a center
again thanks to the Royals and their
entourage tourism began to develop here
the framing for caring on some time the
arrival of the Royals put Lake Tegan's a
well and truly on the map the Bavarian
Royals enjoyed regional specialties and
ensured that the Duggal Bavarian brewery
of tengan Satan became one of the best
in Bavaria it's a tradition that the
hats Alicia Boyce - about pub proudly
cultivates even today
it's equally proud of its knuckle of
pork
and fried potatoes with bacon and beef
and pork loaf the menu also features a
range of desserts and a spicy cheese
spread called pasta another regional
specialty tourists who want to sample
more local cheese's can head to the
Tegan say a Lunt dairy and Coit it's an
association of 21 dairy farmers who all
come from the region visitors are
invited to taste the many cheese's
produced here most of which are named
after the mountains around the lake
bobak and Hirschberg for example
either cases and every G's has a
distinctive flavor it really does some
of them are very strong and aromatic all
cheese is great at this place is really
special it has to be said Bavarians
cherished their impressive culinary
heritage spring water fresh from the
Bavarian Alps supplies the taegons a
fish farm in vivant coin situated in an
altitude of 900 meters above sea level
it's a popular destination for hikers
and nature lovers
and a perfect spot to enjoy a snack
you don't often find fish this good it's
a real delicacy that's why we come here
coming here the fish farm was also
founded by Bavarian Royals more than 150
years ago today its tenants deliver fish
to the best restaurants in the region
including the Yuba fot hotel restaurant
and hot off a gun
the chefs here know that the secret of
quality cuisine is locally sourced
ingredients the produce is as fresh as
it can be and delivered right away
guests can sign up for cooking courses
here which is also a chance to watch the
chefs at work
Christiaan yo guns is Bavaria's most
celebrated chef he has two Michelin
stars to his name
he hopes that his imaginative dishes
captured the spirit and tradition of tag
insane
listen Alice all the ingredients are
locally sourced but we give them a novel
twist so that our dishes are different
from the sort of cooking you get at more
traditional the variant ends full-force
Lake Terrance a not only scenic but also
a paradise for foodies
you